bonsoir et bienvenue il était très
attendu en pleine colère des
agriculteurs Gabriel Atal a donc
présenté sa feuille de route au députés
dans les l'hémicycle un hémicycle plein
à craqué le cap les réformes le style à
tal ça vous regarde spécial déclaration
de politique général du plus jeune
premier ministre de la 5e République
c'est
parti
[Musique]
l'exercice est toujours périlleux à
forciori sans majorité absolue et en
pleine crise agricole le discours de
politique générale c'est un temps fort
de la 5e République pour tout premier
ministre même le plus jeune fraîchement
nommé Gabriel Attal 34 ans a-t-il réussi
son baptême du feu a-t-il su trouver les
mots pour pour convaincre les députés
sur sa vision du pays sa feuille de
route des réformes bonsoir Hugo
bernalicis merci beaucoup d'être là vous
êtes député la France insoumise du Nord
vous venez de voter pour l'IVG dans la
Constitution vos collègues députés ont
fait de même ou pas d'ailleurs ils vont
nous rejoindre dans un tout petit
instant bonsoir Pascal Perino bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté d'être le
grand témoin de cette émission spéciale
une heure en direct pour commenter et
pour décrypter ce discours de Gabriel
Atal le recap il dit qu'en retenir on va
d'abord accueillir Valérie Brochard qui
va nous le dire et nous inviter juste
après bonsoir Valérie bonsoir Miriam
alors que retenir de ce discours de
politique générale bien Gabriel Atal a
présenté sa feuille de route Myriam 1
heure de trajet 1h20 de trajet porte à
porte en roulant bien à droite des
annonces sur sur l'emploi le logement la
santé l'éducation le climat rangé dans
cet ordre un discours adressé aux
députés enfin un discours qui se voulait
résolument tourner vers les classes
moyennes ce qui je le cite ne demande
pas la lune mais simplement à pouvoir
vivre de leur travail alors pour
justement vivre de son travail et bien
Gabriel Attal propose de
desmicardiser la France il a fait ses
propres calculs on l'écoute aujourd'hui
pour augmenter de 100 € le revenu d'un
employé osmic l'employeur doit débourser
238 € de plus quant au salariés il perd
30 9 € de prime d'activité il voit sa
CSG et ses cotisations sociales
augmenter de 26 % et il rentre dans
l'impôt sur le revenu en bref il n'y a
quasiment plus aucun intérêt pour
quiconque à augmenter un salarié au Smic
on ne peut accepter une France où
beaucoup sont condamnés à rester proche
du SMIC toute leur carrière alors oui
j'assume de le dire il faut
désmicardiser la France et dans le le
grand chantier de l'emploi avec un E
majuscule le Premier ministre souhaite
une grande réforme sur les bass salaires
en général qui concernera aussi les
fonctionnaires Gabriel Attal veut
conditionner le RSA à 15 he d'activité
partout sur le territoire il veut par
ailleurs garantir aux Français que
chaque aide soit distribuée à la source
et puis il a promis aujourd'hui une
baisse d'impôt de 2 milliards d'euros
autre dossier qu'on attendait un petit
peu plus haut he dans la structure du du
discours quand je dis on je veux surtout
parler des agriculteurs qui restent
mobilisé encore aujourd'hui sur les
principaux axes autour de la capitale et
partout en région et bien le premier le
premier ministre pardon s'est adressé
directement à eux aussi je le cite
encore notre agriculture est notre force
et notre fierté aussi je le dis ici
solennellement il doit y avoir une
exception agricole française mais une
exception aux yeux de qui aux yeux des
Européens
évidemment au niveau
européen nos trois priorités immédiates
sont claires les jachers les importation
ukrainienne notamment de volaille et le
mercosour ces sujets seront portés sont
portés très fortement par le gver
gouvernement et le président lui-même
nous nous sommes engagés nous avons
engagé une coalition de 22 pays sur la
question déjà chers et nous sommes
proches d'aboutir à une nouvelle
prolongation de la dérogation nous ne
nous laisserons pas faire ok un combat
sur le ring européen d'accord mais sur
notre territoire très concrètement
Gabriel Attal a rappelé les dispositions
fiscales prises la semaine dernière
alors vous aurez le temps évidemment sur
votre plateau de de revenir sur
l'ensemble des annonces mais peut-être
un un dernier point fort à retenir de de
ce discours la santé avec une action
très concrète écoutez agir pour qu'il y
ait plus de médecins devant les Français
les effets de la suppression du numérus
clausus ne se feront pas sentir
immédiatement alors nous devons mettre
en œuvre des solutions fortes tout de
suite c'est pourquoi comme l'a annoncé
le président de la République nous
procéderons à la régularisation des
médecins étrangers sur notre territoire
je vous l'annonce je nommerai un
émissaire chargé d'aller chercher à
l'étranger des médecins qui voudrai
venir exercer en France oui il faut pas
oublier merme que la santé est le
deuxème sujet préoccupation des Français
juste derrière le pouvoir d'achat alors
Gabriel hatal a aussi parlé école climat
sécurité identité mais a-t-il fait un
bon discours et bien comme le disait
Coluche un bon discours ne doit émettre
que des idées avec lesquelles tout le
monde est déjà d'accord avant j'ai comme
un doute Miriam sur le fait que ce soit
le cas je vous laisse en débattre on va
tout de suite leur demander merci
beaucoup Valérie Brochard et venez venez
venez venez on est en direct Antoine
Armand voilà comme ça le le plateau est
complet Antoine Armand député
Renaissance d'où d'Ancy je crois Savo de
Haute Savoie et porte-parole du du
groupe majoritaire ben je vais commencer
avec vous on va faire un tour de table
rapide he parce qu'après on rentre dans
dans le dur des thèmes exercice réussi
ou pas il a il avait un débit on va dire
assez accéléré j'ai pas dit mitraillette
comme d'autres mais c'était rapide vous
vous l'avez trouvé à la hauteur il y
avait du souffle il y avait du souffle
parce que il y avait deux choses qui
sont indispensables dans les périodes de
crise qu'on connaît la première chose
c'est de mettre les mots sur les mots
c'est-à-dire d'oser dire ce qui ne va
pas y compris dans ce qu'on a pu faire
nous-même comme majorité auparavant mais
rappelez aussi le bilan et la constance
le cap qu'il a annoncé au début
souveraineté indépendance du pays
pourquoi pas seulement pour se regarder
l'émirette et dire que la France c'est
le plus beau pays du monde parce qu'on a
besoin de renforcer les démocraties dans
un monde où la fin de l'histoire
heureuse annoncée n'a pas eu lieu n'aura
probablement pas lieu dans les
prochaines années et donc on doit
effectivement réarmer nos Démocr
notre nation et notre continent et donc
dire les Ch de mot ce qui va pas oui
mais dire ce qui ne va pas c'est
extrêmement important et donc catalogue
de mesure de réforme vous diriez de mot
où on est dans la mesure mesurette comme
dit Éric sootti vous avez trouvé qu'il y
avait un une feuille de route vraiment
mais bien sûr et la feuille de route
c'est celle qui est fixée par le
Président de la République depuis 2017
qui consiste à renforcer notre industrie
continuer à rouvrir des usines en France
on le fait depuis 2017 continuer à faire
baisser le chômage on a le taux de
chômage le plus bas depuis 40 ans dans
notre pays pardon mais il y a quelques
mois encore quelques années encore sur
ce plateau on parlait du fléau français
du chômage de masse de l'incapacité à le
maîtriser et voilà qu'il est à son TR
historque c'est important quand vous
parlez au chef d'entreprise il vous
demande de la continuité et puis bien
sûr les chantiers à accélérer à
améliorer je pense à la simplification
je pense évidemment à l'exception
agricole annoncé par on va venir parce
que ce soir alors on n pas encore les
porte-paroes officiels des grands
syndicats agricoles mais la déception
est au rendez-vous ce soir manifestement
on va on va attendre Johan Gillet il
parle d'identité c'est un de vos thèmes
il a peur que la France disparaisse ou
soit dissous il s'adressent aux classes
moyenne ce sont ce sont quand même des
électeurs que vous regardez de près qui
craignent le déclassement ça ça vous
parle non le Premier ministre a surtout
usé de beaucoup de formules finalement
et il y a rien de concret dans ces
paroles il y a aussi beaucoup
d'autosatisfaction et il y a aussi
beaucoup de mensonges parce que le
premier ministre euh a voulu parler
notamment de souveraineté d'identité
mais concrètement euh que fait la
majorité euh sur ces domaines-là rien
euh bien au contraire d'ailleurs puisque
la déconstruction de la France all est
organisé aussi sur le plan européen avec
les députés européen de la majorité
présidentielle qui font tout pour
déconstruire la France et concrètement à
l'issue de ce discours est-ce que les
Français ont des réponses en terme de
pouvoir d'achat la réponse est non en
terme de santé la réponse est non en
terme d'insécurité d'immigration la
réponse est non est-ce que nos
agriculteurs ce soir vont se dire c'est
bon euh le Premier ministre a pris
science de nos problèmes la réponse là
aussi est non donc résultat discours
politique général et rien n la sortie
Hugo Bernal 6 alors vous c'est
particulier vous avez déposé une motion
de défiance de censure avant même qu'il
ne se soit exprimé pourquoi mais parce
que çait pas le coup de l'écouter euh si
si je l'ai écouté d'ailleurs
attentivement c'était assez pénible mais
je l'ai fait quand même non c'est
surtout que on savait à la feuille verte
vous savez qui annonce notre agenda
parlementaire qu'il y aurait un débat
sans vote on le savait à l'avance depuis
que ça a été acté dans not notre ordre
du jour donc pas de vote qui dit
problème de vote de confiance donc nous
avons provoqué un vote de défiance pour
ce qui nous concerne mais un vote en
tant que tel sur le discours de
politique générale du Premier ministre
donc tous les parlementaires auront la
possibilité de dire s'il se penseent
être dans la majorité ou dans
l'opposition S sont dans l'opposition il
votent la motion de censure s'ils sont
dans la majorité il la vote pas comme ça
au moins ça fait le patron du PC dit
Gabriel toucher est-ce que vous êtes
comme lui vous y avez vu un un tournant
libéral alors très clairement euh on est
sur un sur eu en terme de réarmement sur
une déclaration de guerre sociale ça
c'est clair sur quel point précis et ben
sur un certain nombre de points mais par
exemple dire le la location la LSH c'est
terminé maintenant ce sera le RSA hors
de questions que les gens cotisent à la
retraite comme la location Spécifique de
Solidarité la SS ouis la SS pardon euh
donc mais je ve dire euh ces choses-là
le fait de travailler 15hur par semaine
bon après c'est du réchauffer parce que
ça a déjà été voté dans lesém effectiv
l'application de la loi que nous avons
voté ici nous avons voté contre on reste
opposé à ça et en réalité on voit bien
que c'est toujours ce même discours il y
a des emplois disponibles et les gens
vont pas bosser qui sont ces hordes de
fait néant qui ne veulent pas travailler
dans le pays il pas de droit à la
paresse enfin voilà t tous les éléments
de langage classique de de la droite
voire de l'extrême droite ont été repris
dans dans ce
discours l'autorité les classes moyennes
le travail non mais dans le discours
alors il y a la moi je voudrais qu'on
distingue la forme et le fond sur la
forme quelqu'un d'assez incisif de
dynamique oui qui qui va forcément avoir
trouvé un public qui va plaire parce
qu'effectivement contrairement au
discours de l'ancienne premierre
ministre ou de celui encore d'avant on a
quelque chose de plus punchy ça c'est
clair c'est évident donc voilà il y a
une réalité après moi ce que je voudrais
le premier élément que je note c'est que
j'avais un peu le sentiment qu'on
lançait la campagne européenne ce soir
dans cet après-midi midi en fin de
journée dans l'émicycle c'était le débat
d'ailleurs l'exme on va l'écouter
c'était prévu à la fin de ce
débatême gauche bon je vais pas avancer
voilà le RN a écopé à la fin de son
discours mais quand j'entends mon voisin
dire il faut mettre les mots sur les
mots alors oui ça c'est de la
communication je suis d'accord il a fait
un excellent exercice de communication
il a cocher pratiquement toutes les
cases pour nous de de mon point de vue
personnel mais il y a une chose qui me
manque profondément et je viens sur la
le fond c'est que à un moment donné il
dit il faut qu'on maîtrise notre
trajectoire budgétaire déficit et dette
très bien ça fait des années que les
républicains on demande à ce qu'on
respecte notre trajectoire financière
bon moi ça me va bien sauf que quand
j'entends ce qu'il a toutes les mesures
qu'il a annoncé j'ai pas eu le temps de
faire le calcul très honnêtement mais
j'aimerais bien le faire il y a au moins
les 2 milliards de baisses sur les class
baiss d'impôt sur les classes moyennes
mais a pas que ça le SNU généralisé le
service national universel Gén gr pour
vous c'est ça y
aage pour le le le financement du
fauteuil pour les personnes handicapées
enfin il y a énormément de choses le le
logement social si on prend en compte
tout ça on a des dépenses je n'ai pas vu
où étai les recettes c'estàdire que si
on veut un équilibre budgétaire moi je
suis à la commission des finances je
suis assez pragmatique il y a des
dépenses annoncées où sont les recettes
alors vous allez répondre ine Armand
mais on a un grand témoin qui en a vu he
c'est c'est l'avantage d'avoir un peu de
de mémoire des discours de politique
général certains ont dit Gabriel Sarkozi
est-ce que vous l'avez retrouvé est-ce
qu'il va rester il va faire date ce
discours selon vous Pascal ou d'
certaine manière il va faire date de par
l'âge de celui qui prenait la parole
c'était tout de même la première fois
qu'un aussi jeune premier ministre
prenait la parole avec une expérience
politique quand vous prenez descritur
objectif relativement faible donc il
courrait un risque surtout rajoutons que
le contexte n'est pas un contexte
extrêmement porteur c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire et que la mise en place de
son gouvernement a été difficile donc
tout le monde l'attendait au tournant
s'aurait pu être par exemple un
véritable dérapage certains s'y
attendaient en disant au fond il a pas
les épaules il a pas le style pour ça il
a surpris son monde il a surpris son
monde il a surpris son monde parce que
le discours je ne prononce pas sur le
fond on va pouvoir aborder des thèmes
ont déjà été abordés sur le fond il a
tenu la route pendant
1h20 il a su mêler à la fois des
propositions qui peuvent être parfois
apparaître presque trop concrète mais
c'est le style àal hein c'est le style
àal des propositions extrêmement
concrètes il faudra qu'il assure le
suivi de toutes ces propositions
concrètes extrêmement nombreuses qu'il a
avancé et et les a mis d'une certaine
manière en scène au travers des quatre
thèmes qu'il avait retenu et au travers
au fond d'un double mouvement où là il
renoue avec au fond en même temps
macronien des débuts c'est-à-dire qu'il
a commencé avec 1989 son âge en disant
le l'homme jeune que je suis constate
que la France va mal que la France est
inquiète et il s'agit de lui redonner du
punch et dans la forme c'est vrai que
c'était un ministre qui était un
ministre
punchy et puis en même temps il a dit au
fond l'essentiel pour redonner du punch
c'est libérer libéré et là on retrouve
des thèmes qui étaient les thèmes
d'emmanuelc tout à fait déverrouillé
dmicardisé ça c'était un peu nouveau et
cetera mais on voit bien lui son sa
ligne c'est en effet la France a besoin
d'être déburaucratisé voilà alors on va
y venir et puis dans un deuxième temps
ça c'est la la deuxième partie du
discours c'est tout de même un discours
qui est un discours marqué
par une profonde croyance de ce jeune
homme dans les vertus de l'autorité dans
les vertus de l'autorité quel qu'elle
soit on l'a vu quand il parle de l'école
on l'a vu quand il parle de des réformes
aussi il dit voilà je vais suivre ça
très attentivement j'aurai ma feuille de
route et je regarderai et cetera parole
performtive il y a il y a un mélange
mais ça n'est pas dernier point si vous
voulez ça n'est pas l'ombre de son
maître parce que beaucoup je crois que
le rassemblement national avait dit
c'est pas la peine de l'écouter puisque
c'est la voix de son maître hein et là
voy c'est pas la voix de son maître il a
fait sentir sa différence alors pas
autant que Fabius par rapport à mitteran
lui c'est lui moi c'est moi mais il y
avait une vraie différence il ne parle
par exemple pas du tout comme Macron
hein le rhythme le style la longueur des
phrases la syntaxe ça n'est absolument
pas Macron hein c'est bien il y a pas de
lirisme non plus alors on va reparler du
style mais là on va venir sur le fond
avec les élus parce que on a même une
sémiologue qui viendra à la fin de cette
émission sur la question de la dette
c'est intéressant est-ce que vous êtes
pas tout simplement en train de
distribuer de l'argent que la France n'a
pas mais non et d'ailleurs je pense que
les débats qui viennent d'avoir lieu sur
le plateau en témoigne d'abord nous
tenons notre objectif de désendettement
et nous tenons l'objectif que nous nous
sommes fixés au début du quinquena
d'être sous 3 % de déficit en 2027 dans
un monde non pas seulement perturbé mais
heurté par l'invasion
comm Mar dit je ne vois pas les
économies c'est vrai que il y a pas de
parag certain sur le plateau mais ce que
j'entends c'est que certains sur le
plateau disent que nous serions les
pires austéritaires de l'histoire de la
5e République et d'autres nous
expliquent d'autres d'ailleurs dont nous
attendons je le dis avec cordialité
toujours les mesures d'économie
budgétaire que la dernière fois qu'on a
fait une proposition sur les retraites
vous avez souhaité l'amander pour
augmenter le déficit et d'autres nous
disent au contraire que nous sommes
dispendieux au fond et c'est ce que
viens de dire PASC Perino on essaie de
trouver un équilibre entre libérer les
énergies et ça c'est ce que nous
demandent les Français et c'est pas de
droite ou de gauche ils nous disent on
voudrait faire que ce soit dans la
socitif que ce soit dans l'associatif on
aimerait déposer des dossiers plus
simplement pour pouvoir aider que ce
soit dans le secteur médico-social dans
le secteur de la santé on passe plus de
temps à faire de l'administratif que du
soins ou dans les entreprises et
l'agriculture donc moins de norm moins
de normes
deation pas se d'ailleurs à
propos qu'elles existent et qu'elles
sont demandé par nos compatriotes qu'on
les applique correctement la loigalime
les contrôles tout simplement les
contrôle aux frontières a bien compris
que la chasse aux normes et à tout ce
qui est bucratie ouver donne la parole G
on va rejoindream d'Ava on va faire un
tout petit tour des réactions à
l'Assemblée nationale vous avez tous
suivi les principaux chefs de partis
d'opposition j'imagine n'applaudissent
pas bien évidemment c'est assez
traditionnel dans une déclaration de
politique générale c'est la majorité
appudit les oppositions llu il y a un
concours de décibel dans l'hémicycle
c'était un hémicycle assez survolté il y
avait aussi énormément de journalistes
dans les tribunes et vous l'avez dit
Gabriel hatal il a été pas mal chahuté
il s'est pas démonté il a dit je ne
m'arrêterai pas malgré les hurlements et
puis les oppositions elles ont eu de
nombreuses critiques contre le Premier
ministre alors c'était pas forcément
très original mais elles lui ont
reproché tour à tour d'ê jeune m RAC que
ce n'était pas lui qui décidait mais
Emmanuel Macron et puis que c'était un
premier minist des riches et de l'entre
soi écouter ce florilège des punchlin
des oppositions concocté par Clément
perouau nous défendons la France des
rond-points des sous-préfectures vous
défendez la France du rond-point des
Champs-Élysées votre œuvre destructrice
Monsieur le Premier Ministre abandonne
les plus faibles à ce que vous pensez
être leur destin de perdant je vous ai
écouté vous êtes le jeune visage du
vieux monde tcher sortez du corps de
notre premier ministre parce que comme
le dit le poète qu on est réque on est
réque Monsieur le Premier Ministre
madame oua Castera partage avec vous un
arrondissement du lycée Stanislas à
l'École alsacienne on se comprend bien
entre grands bourgeois les Français en
métropole ou en outremère n'en peuvent
plus des discours creux de vos
catalogues La Redoute de promesse jamais
tenu il ne sert à rien de vouloir écoper
le bateau qui fait haut quand les
membres de l'équipage aux ordres du
commandant s'active en même temps à
ouvrir des voies d'eau partout dans la
coque
voilà merci beaucoup Elsa un tout petit
mot pardonnez-moi je vous interromps non
justement après cette prise de parole
des oppositions Gabriel Atal qui avait
été un peu peut-être corseté he par son
discours d'une d'unh20 a été beaucoup
plus offensif notamment en rappelant au
députés rassemblement national leur vote
au Parlement européen beaucoup plus
offensif un peu plus libéré à une prise
de parole plus courte plus directe après
donc les prises de parole successiv des
oppositions merci beaucoup Elsa à tout
de suite je voudrais qu'on prenne
quelques thèmes il y avait beaucoup de
choses donc comme il y a beaucoup de
redit aussi c'est vrai qu'il y avait la
conférence de presse du président cette
réforme des bass salaires ça à ma
connaissance c'est nouveau la
smicardisation de la société on la
constate en France contrairement à nos
voisins les salaires bas sont coincés
n'arrive pas à facilement augmenter
est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps de tous
vous réunir pour dire on revient sur les
aides sociales qui fait que sur
légèrement audessus du SMIC on permet
l'évolution des salaires e gilet sur les
bas salaires il y a de nombreux Français
qui gagnent mal leur vie et dont le
travail ne leur permet pas de vivre
dignement et nous nous avions fait des
proposition mais là ce qu'a fait Gabriel
Atal c'est pas une proposition
pardonnez-moi mais dire je ne veux pas
une France de la de la smicardisation
bah c'est bien mais ça veut dire quoi il
dit faire évoluer un systèème qui nous a
conduit depuis des décennies à
concentrer nos aides au niveau du
salaire minimum dire qu'iloir les
mesures que nous proposons de bon sens à
savoir permettre aux employeurs comme le
propose Marine Le Pen d'augmenter de 10
% les salaires avec une exonération de
charge patronale il s'y oppose
systématiquement et le gouvernement s'y
est toujours opposé la majorité
présidentielle s est toujours opposé
donc quand on propose des choses
concrètes nous contrairement à ces
belles paroles qui n'ont rien de
concrète euh on peut pas dire finalement
qu'il s'intéresse euh à ce que gagnent
les Français parce que dans son discours
en général il n'y a rien nu sur le
pouvoir d'achat des Français et
rappelons-le aujourd'hui de nombreux
Français sont obligés de choisir entre
ce so se nourrir c'est la réalité
aujourd'huic que vous venez de dire
chers collègues c'est vraiment la
manifestation de votre incohérence et de
votre incapacité à gouverner vous avez
demandé il y a quelques mois la retraite
à 60 ans
avec Mar
Leen vous avez demandé des milliards
supplémentaires pour les dépenses
sociales attendez vous avez demandé des
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires
dans le secteur social et vous voulez
aujourd'hui supprimer les cotisations
qui permettent de le financer sur
la
lesorte quoi je sais
MAJ je
vais pzite ridit pas
lebiste de Marine Le Pen était très
clair c'était une retraite à 60 ans pour
les personnes ayant commencé à
travailler avant 20 ans pourquoi parce
que ces personnesl et bien sont les
personnes ayant les travails les plus
difficiles au-delà c'est progressif la
présidentielle si vous voulez
bien la réforme des retraites est passé
Marie Chistine les républicains tiens
pourrait voter ça cette remise en cause
des aides sociales juste audessus du
SMIC pour essayer de de faire monter les
salaires dans ce pays moi on parle de
desmicardisation de la France déjà j'ai
appris j'ai appris un terme qui est
assez nouveau mais on va parler
récemment prochainement la réalité c'est
quoi si vous voulez augmenter les
salaires parce que l'État BO être
employeur avec un grand nombre de
fonctionnaires il y a quand même la
majorité des employeurs des salariés ils
sont dans les entreprises et quand vous
allez commencer à annoncer aux
entreprises qu'il faut revaloriser de 10
ou de 15 % l'ensemble des salaires moi
j'aimerais bien savoir alors qu'ils sont
pour certaines avec certaines
entreprises sont ont des difficultés
pour rembourser le pr garanti par l'État
le PGE qui avait été mis en place au
moment de la crise du covid euh
j'aimerais bien savoir comment nos
employeurs vont faire alors après il y a
toujours la solution effectivement de
supprimer les cotisations sociales
patronnales ou salarial ou les deux
c'est-à-dire que les patrons disent au
fond on n'est pas incité parce qu'on
perd les aides quand on augmente
légèrement les salaires c'est ce que je
comprends dans les trappes à B salair
POS deux de deux problème c'est que déjà
je sais pas qui finance le modèle social
qu'on a aujourd'hui si effectivement on
exonère de cotisation les les
augmentations de salaire première chose
et deuxième chose la compétitivité de
nos entreprises françaises on est dans
un marché international je vois vraiment
pas comment elles vont s'en sortir et le
troisième élément il y a une réalité
aujourd'hui qui fait que si vous
augmentez le SMIC que le SMIC vous allez
et c'est ce que il a très bien dit à un
moment donné Gabriel hatal il y avait
une cinquantaine d'entreprises qui
rémunérait leurs salariés avec la
dernière augmentation du SMIG qui se
trouvait en dessous du SMIG quand vous
avez des salariés aujourd'hui dans
certaines filières qui sont en dessous
du SMIC parce que le SMIG a augmenté
vous voyez la course un ça il a dit
qu'il fallait que les partenaires
sociaux s'engag dans toutes les branches
à supprimer
çaous on met tout le monde au SMIC alors
c'est ça le vrai Bernal ici ça c'est
intéressant parce que vous vous voulez
indexer les salaires sur sur l'inflation
il y a un vrai sujet quand même en
France sur le diagnostic vous le
reconnaissez il y a un sujet sur les bas
salaires oui il y a tellement un sujet
que nous avons déposé non pas dans cette
liche mais dans la précédente une
proposition
de de de loi qui prévoyait
l'augmentation du SMIC d'ailleurs qui se
fait par décret donc c'était plutôt
mettre le pied dans la porte pour que le
débat puisse avoir lieu parce que nous
pensons que l'augmentation du SMIC est
nécessaire le salaire dans son entier
parce que faut pas se voliler la face
les cotisations sociales c'est du
salaire aussi c'est du salaire différé
qui servent à la sécurité sociale à
avoir des droits quand on dit il faut
que les gens puissent avoir des sous
pour se soigner bah oui justement il
faut mettre dans la caisse de la
sécurité sociale et pas dérembboursé
parce que les gens faut qu'ils puissent
se soigner retrait aussi et les
retraites aussi exactement donc pour de
ce point de vue nous sommes assez
cohérents à la France insoumise on
augmente certes les dépenses mais aussi
les recettes donc tout va bien sur
l'équilibre en question et il faut à un
moment donné se dire qu'effectivement il
y a des entreprises qui ne pourraient
pas amortir une augmentation du schmic
telle que nous la suggérons et donc nous
avons penser qu'une une caisse de
péréquation entre les très grosses
entreprises et les très petites pourrait
être bien que la solidarité puisse
marcher aussi entre elles vu que elle le
prennent en général parce que le
savez-vous les très grandes entreprises
payent en moyenne 8 % de cotisation et
impôt sur les les sociétés diverses et
variées c'est le grand évitement fiscal
si il payit si elle payit 33 % comme la
petite entreprise qui n'a pas le choix
qu' y a pas de conseiller fiscal qui met
pas dans les paradis fiscaux peut-être
qu'il y aurait un peu plus de caisse
là-dedans mais quand même les
macronistes ont beau jeu de de de
pointer le rassemblement national en
disant ah regardez vous voulez pas que
les cotisations sociales puissent être
financé mais c'est eux qui ont fait
d'abord les exonérations de charges en
général pas juste pour le SMIC pour
toutes les
entreprises
loin le C qui rent
comme règle générale et commun y a plus
rien dans les caisses oui oui et quand
on a proposé de taxer les super profit
il y avait plus personne il y avait plus
personne
ou à penser cette question d'une
certainere
MRE pour continuer les
exonération ouvre un débat donc soyez
bref s'il vous plaît sur les salair très
brivement ce que le premier ministre a
annoncé à la fois comme vision et comme
mesure concrète c'est une demande qu'on
entend tous les jours et je pense tous
autour de ce plateau dans nos
circonscriptions mieux vivre de son
travail donc ça passe par une discussion
des partenaires sociaux je me permets
quand même de rappeler sur ce plateau
que ce sont les partenaires sociaux qui
peuvent
fixer les salair écoutez soyez pas
insultant deuxièmement une
baisse pour les classes moyennes à de
nature de l'ordre de 2 milliards et je
dis un point sur les baisses d'impôts
parce que on dit toujours les impôts
c'est une catastrophe on baisse impô
nous avons baissé les impôts comme
personn depuis
2017 les classes moyenes les trouvez où
qui pay ministre a annoncé qu'elle
serait financé et nous feront des
propositions d'économie dans le prochain
budjet donne cet exemple les impôts sur
les sociétés ont baissé en France nous
avons fait baisser à 25 % les rentrées
fiscales sont supérieures pourquoi parce
que quand vous redonnez de l'argent aux
personnes qui créent de l'emploi ou aux
personnes qui consomment en France et
bien ça a un impact économique c'est pas
aussi facile aussi
Simp qui consiste à dire bien que sur
cette mesure qui ser d'achat on continue
on pl
maisver sur le pouvoir d'achat on a
augmenté plus que l'inflation le SMIC
depuis 2 ans bon la satisfa si on l'a eu
tout à l'heure c'est bon tout ce que
vous avez fait positif c'est parfait euh
ça saurait parce que la France la France
irait un petit peu mieux si tout avait
été parfait mais les espoirs quand vous
dites on fera les économies plus tard
oui les dépenser tout de suite les
économies plus tard ça c'est on connaît
ça fait 16 ans et demi que je suis
député j'ai vu ça depuis 16 ans et demi
la réalité c'est que le gouvernement
quand il nous parle de réarmement et
industrielle de la souveraineté
industrielle c'est qu'il espère que
l'économie se portera beaucoup mieux et
qu' on aura effectivement une continuité
d'augmentation des recettes fiscales qui
pourront financer ces dépenses mais rien
n'est acquis aujourd'hui rien n'est
àquis alors je voudrais qu'on parle un
tout petit peu des agriculteurs et puis
je vous donne la suite du programme de
de l'autorité et des différentes mesures
pour faire respecter toutes les les
figures qui la représent dans notre
République comme ça soyez bref les
agriculteurs comment on en sort parce
que c'est vrai que on attendait Pascal
on s'attendait à des à des mesures
nouvelles par rapport à cell annoncé la
semaine dernière il y a peu de choses il
y a juste la confiance qu'à Bruxelles le
président pourra emmener une vingtaine
de pays pour reporter un certain nombre
de règles notamment sur les sur les
jachers oui parce que vous voyez de
manière évidente que l'on est dans une
séquence européenne d'ailleurs juste
avant le premier ministre le président
de la République intervenait de Suède et
a déjà abordé ce sujet en disant qu'il
allait se por très fermement sur ce
dossier à Bruxelles donc on est dans la
la séquence européenne il s'agissait
d'une déclaration de politique générale
vous n'imaginez pas une déclaration de
politique générale entièrement consacrée
à des mesures concernant sur les
barrages il écoutaient hein ils
attendaient le paragraphe avec des
mesures nouvelles cement certainement
mais si vous voulez il ne s'adressait
pas simplement aux agriculteurs ce soir
il s'adressait à l'ensemble du pays et
il fixa un cap pour pour son
gouvernement euh donc je j'étais sûr que
la déclaration de politique générale ne
ferait pas refluer les tracteurs qui se
sont portés vers Paris et qui cherche à
bloquer plus ou moins efficacement la
capitale non ça viendra des rencontres
et des rencontres pas simplement des
rencontres un peu médiatiques sur le tas
même si c'est bien d'envoyer le symbole
d'un Premier ministre qui va au charbon
qui n'hésite pas à aller sur le terrain
mais ça ça viendra bien sûr mais ça
viendra si vous voulez des négociations
avec les organisations syndicales parce
qu'on est dans un milieu tout à fait
spécifique vous savez les syndicats ça
ne représente pas grand-chose en France
sauf dans un secteur le monde agricole
hein 8 % des salariés français sont 8
%qu il a raison mais mais là vous avez
un monde qui le monde agricole dans
lequel il y a une présence d'un acteur
syndical ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il y
a pas de pluralisme syndical on le voit
hein il y a la coordination donc la
position de la FNSEA de la Confédération
et centrale vous aux affaires qu'est-ce
que vous fait il y a Bruxelles il y a
les fameux traité de libre échange il y
a les négociations sur le fameux Green
Deal mais il y a vous aux affaires en
France pour le moment qu'est-ce que vous
feriez on voit bien que c'est un
mouvement htéroclite qu' n'y a pas une
seule revendication qu'est-ce que vous
feriez vous pour
essayerér faut en la matière quand le
Premier ministre et le président de la
République et quasiment l'ensemble de la
majorité présidentielle finissent par
avouer parce que et bien les
agriculteurs mettent la pression sur le
gouvernement que les traités de libre
échange sont en partie nocifs pour notre
agriculture je vous répond en même temps
les députés européens de renaissance
votent un éè traité qui vient tuer notre
agriculture c'est le cas il y a 3 jours
au Parlement européen tout à fait
ensuite vous avez le Premier ministre
qui dit finalement on va taper du point
sur la table et on va obtenir de l'Union
européenne des avancées et en même temps
c'est drôle hein parce que en même temps
la la
présidenteyen a désavoué président de la
République pas plus tard qu'auourd'hui n
ce qu'on ferait c'est très clair on
n'approuverait pas ce genre de traité et
on réclame un moratoire sur les traités
de libre échange qui viennent pourrir la
vie de nos agriculteurs et qui ne leur
permettent pas de vivre de leur travail
ça c'est essentiel on remettra aussi et
bien une sorte de priorité nationale
dans la commande publique pour nos
produits locaux par exemple çaut deux
exemples non mais on peut très bien
négocier les traités et mettre des
clauses miroir également dans ces
traités le problème c'est qu'aujourdui
non non aujourd'hui il faut non il faut
user de techniqu pour réussir à avoir un
maximum de
produits est-ce qu'il y a de poids de
mesur en macronie sur les traités de
libre échange la Nouvelle-Zélande la
Chilie c'est oui de mercosour avec
l'Amérique latine Brésil Argentine c'est
nonom non on on tient une ligne très
claire qui consiste à ne pas être
simpliste sur les accords de libre
échange les accord de libre échange
peuvent bénéficier et bénéficient à
l'agriculture française dans tout un tas
de domaines je pourrais citer les
fromages de qualité les alcool je cite
évidemment le secteur viticool le le
monde girondin qui ne pourrait pas
aujourd'hui subsister avoir cette
rentabilité sans certains traités y
compris certains secteurs laitiers et et
beauovvin avec les derniers traités avec
l'Amérique du Nord mais dans le même
temps on ne peut pas se livrer à une
concurrence déloyale donc le combat du
président de la République c'est de
fixer ce qu'on appelle le terme est pas
très clair des clauses miroires pour
dire concurrence loyal climatique social
et économique est-ce que c'est ce que
nous avons fait dans les traités précéd
Norte pas ce que nous interdisons
exactement c'est ce que nous avons fait
dans les traités précédents et c'est
pour ça que nous refusons aujourd'hui
que moi avec d'autres collègues j'ai
signé une tribune contre le Mercosur la
difficulté qu'on rencontr moi je je dis
les choses très honnêtement la
difficulté que nous rencontrons et je le
dis avec la modestie qui s'impose sur le
sujet tant la colère des agriculteurs et
les éleveurs de certains secteur je
pense aux in ou au au volaill est
légitime c'est le contrôle c'est la
capacité à le vérifier et donc oui il
faut qu'on sorte d'une forme de naïveté
selon laquelle la Commission européenne
les services de l'État peuvent appliquer
simplement efficacement tous ces va
laisser la crise agricole là parce que
on va voir dans jeudi comment ça va se
passer je vais qu'on on parle aussi des
sujets régaliens que vous connaissez
Hugo Bernal sur l'agriculture je pense
que c'est vraiment dommage parce qu'il a
fait un un paquet d'annonces et
notamment il a parlé des volailles du CR
oui et et moi j'ai été marqué par cette
expression parce que que ce soit les
céréales les céréaliers ou les les
volaillers sur le problème de l'Ukraine
il y a une vraie question de la part de
nos agriculteurs aujourd'hui et c'est
complètement dans le champ européen on a
laissé depuis la guerre pour expliquer
no tléspectateurs effectivement il y a
un sujet et puis franchement les normes
si elles sont pas rigoureusement
appliquées de façon identique par
l'ensemble des pays européens on doit
pouvoir
dénoncer oncer simplement ses accords
c'est pas possible alors on va consacrer
un débat complet jeudi à l'issue de ce
sommet européen l'autorité en quelques
mot façon formule choc Gabriel hatal
voilà ce que ça donne tu casses tu
répares tu ses tu nettoies tu défies
l'autorité on t'apprend à la
respecter voilà ho bernalisis on a pris
cette formule choc parce que peut-être
qu'elle va elle va rester c'est un
rapport avec les agriculteurs non je
parle de l'autorité vous demande he
parce que on sait plus bien sur quel
pied
danserre parlait sécurité où il parlait
autorité il a parlé de l'uniforme à
l'école qui serait peut-être généralisé
il a parlé aussi d'une peine pour les
moins de 16 ans nouveaux intérêt travaux
d'intérêts généraux en gros ça mérite
d'être clair non oui oui ça le mérite de
clair d'être clair c'est c'est
malheureusement un retour en arrière au
siècle dernier là c'est dans la
proposition concrète c'est même pas dans
le
style de Gabriel Attal parce que je sais
pas si vous savez qu' existe déjà
aujourd'hui la réparation pénale pour
les mineurs de moins de 16 ans qui
permet à celui qui casse qui répare en
fait et qui est prononcé par le
procureur de la République et le juge
enfin proposé par le procureur ensuite
le juge au tribunal pour enfant et et
donc en fait la la grosse différence
entre la réparation pénale c'est qu'elle
a sortie dans un ensemble de mesures y
compris des mesures éducatives qu' y a
pas que un versant et un volet répressif
là le travail d'intérêt général au moins
c'est clair il y a pas d'accompagnement
c'est juste ah tu vas bosser
gratuitement comme le font les adultes
sachant que le signal qu'on lance c'est
quand même qu'on va faire travailler des
enfants c'est quand même ça le signal
hein très concrètement al bien sûr il y
a intérêt général parce que comme ça ça
rend bien ça rend mieux mais c'est ça
elle est où la vertu pédagogique non on
voit bien le coup de menton on voit bien
ce que ça ce que ça produit comme effet
mais est-ce que ça aura un effet sur le
nombre d'infractions commises par des
mineurs dans le pays parce que c'est au
fond c'est ça le sujet hein si on dit
voilà il y a des mineurs qui sont en
rupture avec la loi et donc on voudrait
savoir si si ça va améliorer les choses
bien sûr que non c'est de l'effet
annonces pour plaire à un électorat qui
on envie qu'on parle durement qu'on
parle comme il a parlé là la tribune
qu'on fasse comme ça qu'on qu'on tape du
point sur la table voilà tout ça ne sert
à
rien et pourquoi on l'a pas mis dans le
code justice pénale des mineurs pourquoi
Éric Dupont Moretti il a pas pensé avant
hein lui qui est arrivé sur ce texte là
particulièrement dans la dans la
mandature précédente parce que ça sert à
rien voilà get je pense qu'il faut pas
il faut pas tout mélanger effectivement
le Premier ministre a usé de formules
des slogans toujours et toujours en
l'occurrence si on veut de la vraie
fermeté parce que la délinquence chez
les mineurs est un vrai sujet il faut
supprimer l'excuse de minorité et c'est
ce que nous avons proposé à plusieurs
reprises au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale systématiquement refusé mais
c'estàdire que quand on est mineur la
loi devrait déterminer et bien que
finalement on n'est pas excusé de par sa
sa minorité donc on doit être devant un
juge le droit des majeurs s'applique
avec avec voilà un âge à définir juste
une rupture la Convention internationale
des dro de
l'fantess on l'
vumi lors des émeutes vous savez tous
ces gens qui ont commis des émeutes dans
les quartiers une partie de votre
éctorat sûrement d'ailleurs et de gens
que vous souteniez parceque vous avez eu
du bal à les condamner ces émeutes et
bien beaucoup étaient
mineurs les Français les Français et
bien non parce que les
agriculteurs d' de l'ordre notamment
mais à un moment donné il faut prendre
conscience que les Français réclament de
la fermeté parce que les Français on ont
marre de cette insécurité et de cette
impunité qui touche toute une part de la
société donc effectivement si le premier
ministre veut vraiment agir qu'il
reprenne et bien nos propositions de loi
que nous avons déposé et qu'il aille
dans le sens que on voit bien je me
permet que c'est bien ce discours permet
de faire le marchepied à l'extrême
droite voilà le fil conduur du discours
pas que là-dessus sur l'ensemble des
sujet par
duus je c'est un débat et en même temps
on essaie de commenter le discours
peut-être le moment le plus politique
quand Gabriel Atal devient le chef de
fil de la campagne des européennes
regardez ceux qui prônent la fin de
l'application des traités sont les
partisans d'un frxit déguisé qui
affaiblirait la France moins d'Europe
c'est moins de puissance pour la France
je ne prendrai qu'un exemple et il fera
mal à certains ici le brexit ces
partisans promettaient des jours heureux
à l'économie britannique et au peuple
anglais la semaine dernière à cause du
brexit les derniers ha fourneau de
Grande-Bretagne fermé on ne produit plus
d'acier au Royaume-Uni nous en France au
contraire notamment grâce aux
investissements de l'Europe l'industrie
revient là il est il est attendu sur ce
rôle làà en fait Gabriel hatal c'est
c'est lui qui mène la campagne vous
organisez déjà le face à faceace avec le
rassemblement national non mais il y a
pas de face- à faceace entre un premier
ministre de 34 ans qui vient de faire
son discours de politique générale
d'annoncer des mesuresutorité faire et
et le président d'un parti qui n'a
jamais été élu qui est complètement
absent du Parlement européen et qui se
contredit entre ce qui dit à
bruxel comprend ça vous je vais quand
même finir Parlement européen qu même
arver à à mettre en accord ces votes ce
serait un pas supplémentaire ce qui
compte ici ce qui compte ici c'est de
dire que quand on est au responsabilités
oui c'est un petit peu plus compliqué et
donc quand on est français et qu'on
arrive dans les enceintes européennes
pour la politique agricole commune on se
bat qu'est-ce qu'on a obtenu dans la
dernière politique agricole commune
s'assurer que les jeunes agriculteurs
aient un montant d'aide minimum
continueer
les Aes de la politique agricole commune
mais c'est ce que je disis tout àheure
sur l'application continuer à augmenter
verdissement des aides de la politique
agricole commune et continuer à faire de
la France le premier bénéficiaire net
tout en corrigeant ces inéquités et
faire des compromis c'est ce que nous
faisons au niveau européen avec le
Parlement européen que nous avons avec
la Commission européenne ensuite quand
vous allez dire comme le rassemblement
national quand vous allez dire comme le
rassemblement national à tous vos
électeurs et à tous les agriculteurs qui
se plaignent parfois à juste titre de la
PAC sur le terrain vous avez raison
c'est affreux et que vous l'avez voter
au Parlement européen vous êtes pris en
flagrant délit d'inconséquence et c'est
ça qui supporte les franç Mar Christine
Dall dans cette période en pleine crise
des agriculteurs est-ce que l'Europe
peut être encore suscité de l'adhésion
moi je croyais qu'on était sur la notion
d'autorité du du du premier minist j'ai
avancé on a avancé crois que je crois
que l'Europe aujourd'hui alors il a eu
une phrase que j'ai beaucoup aimé il a
dit quand la bureaucratie recule la
liberté avance je crois que c'est
exactement j'ai dû prendre des
guillemets la bureaucratie qui recule
c'est la liberté qui avance
on peut le mettre au niveau de l'Europe
on peut le mettre partout la réalité
c'est qu'il faudrait que l'État français
arrête de créer des commissions truc me
des des enquêtes sur je sais pas quoi
enfin on est sans arrêt en train de
créer de nouvelles structures donc ça
vous le saluer ce choc de simplification
justement moi j'attends de voir les
fittes vous savez il y a 2 ans on avait
une
direction la DG AFP en France qui
s'occupait de la fonction publique de
tous les agents de la fonction publique
a créé il y a 2 ans la diise la
direction interministérielle de
l'encadrement supérieur de l'État on n'a
pas supprimé la première on a rajoutter
une centaine de collaborateurs qui
s'occupent de l'encadrement supérieur de
l'État c'est le mal franco-français si
aujourd'hui moi j'ai envie de faire
confiance sur sa capacité à réduire
toutes ces structures qui pour moi sont
complètement inutiles aujourd'hui et qui
coûtent beaucoup d'argent au budget
français si on arrive à faire ça et
quand monsieur disait qu'on avait pas
fait de proposition on vous a posé dans
le budget de l'année dernière de la
sobriété
administrative avz suivi on serait on
a'urait pas on aurait réduit un temps
soit peu le déficit voilà on est on est
capable d'exister la France insoumise et
aux républicains dans cette campagne
européenne qui qui s'annonce quand on
voit déjà le le ton qui est donné par
Gabriel hatal qui désigne clairement
l'adversaire comme s'il n'y avait que
deux possibilités de vote dans cette
campagne oui je crois qu'on sait faire
campagne sans avoir besoin d' populiste
on l'a montré à plusieurs reprises on
continuera d'en faire la démonstration
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que même
au rassemblement national on prétend
avoir telle ou telle position au
Parlement européen quand on vérifie
quand on gratte de plus près c'est
toujours un peu plus compliqué que ça et
compris le groupe dans laquel il siège à
majoritairement valider tous les traités
de libre échange alors que le groupe
dans lequel nous siégeons est pour le
coup pur et parfait de ce point de vue-l
on peut pas nous en faire le reproche on
peut avoir le débat politique le
désaccord mais on a on a quand même
là-dessus des clarification qui sont
plus intéressantes à gauche pour ce qui
est de de la France insouis même si je
pense qu'il serait plus utile qu'on ait
une liste commune de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale je le
redis à parten plutôt que d'aller se
disséminer à droite non mais je le dis
ça fait parti du débat du débat oui mais
bon tant que les list sont pas déposé
tout est possible et
l' moi je pense sincèrement qu'on peut
faire confiance à notre tête de liste
qui est François Xavier bami qui connaî
bien le sujet qui s'est beaucoup investi
et qui justement a un regard toujours
très attentif sur les consécesê j'ai pas
terminé parce que qui va un travail avec
son équipe on a une victoire politique
sur la reconnaissance des des
travailleurs détachés comme travailleurs
uberisés pardon comme étant des
travailleurs en tant que tel et pas des
auto-entrepreneurs c'est une bataille
qu'on a mené au niveau européen même si
on conteste le cadre en tant que tel de
l'Union européenne rien ne nous empla
d'essayer d'arracher des victoires
politiques pour les plus faibles et
voilà on va terminer avec d'unava Elsa
le Premier ministre a annoncé quelques
projets de loi pas tant que ça sur
l'économie principalement est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre à des bras de fer aussi
homériqu dans les mois qui viennent à
l'Assemblée comme le 493 sur les
retraites ou ça peut passer alors
écoutez des projets de loi il y en aura
du travail il y en aura ici à
l'Assemblée on annonce un projet de loi
industrie verte 2 un projet de loi sur
l'aide active à mourir vous savez ça
fait assez consensus dans les Mims même
si les débats risquent d'être riches un
projet de loi sur Mayotte et puis vous
en parliez un projet de loi justice des
mineurs avec notamment la création des
travaux d'intérêt éducatifs pour les
jeunes et des travaux d'intérêt général
pour les parents d'enfants délinquants
dans le législatif ça ce sera à
l'automne dans le budget les basses
d'impôts pour les classes moyennes ça a
priori le budget c'est toujours avec un
493 et puis des grosses réformes sur le
logement sur le marché du travail ça
nécessitera peut-être de passer par le
législatif ou alors tout se réglera d'un
point de vue réglementaire on le sait le
gouvernement veut axer ses réformes
justement pour aller vite sur des
réformes réglementaires ce qu'on sait
aussi qui passera par le réglementaire
c'est la réforme de l'Ame l'aide
médicale d'État ça ça fait des
mécontents chez les républicains qui
s'estiment trahi alors comment on va
faire passer tout ça myiam ben c'est
toujours le même enjeu il y a toujours
pas de majorité peut-être desésaccords
avec la droite oui mais il faudra régler
ce problème de la réforme de l'aide
médicale d'État puisque Eric soti était
particulièrement en colère de cette
annonce de du Premier ministre tout à
l'heure merci beaucoup Éric sioti qui
parle de même de de trahison vous l'avez
dit merci els Mondin Gava on s'arrête là
on suivra les éventuels projets de loi
les éventuelles batailles parlementaires
qui sont issues directement de de ce
discours de politique général vous
restez avec moi Pascal Perino parce
qu'on va parler à présent uniquement de
la forme avec notre sémiologue Mariette
d'igrand et le communiquant Philippe Mor
chevrelet qui nous rejoignent juste
après ce sujet Hélène monduel n'a rien
manqué de la gestuelle et des mots
employés par le Premier ministre
regardez concentré mais détendu
gabrielal prend même le temps de
s'arrêter pour une photo quelques
minutes avant son
discours le plus jeune premier ministre
de la 5e République sait qu'il est
attendu et il assume il prend même
exemple sur sa génération je suis né en
1989 notre génération partout dans le
monde voit son monde chambouler plus
fortement encore que tout autre avant
elle elle est en proie au doutes face au
doutes un mot que Gabriel Atal a
prononcé à de nombreuses reprises au
début de son discours il faut créer de
l'espoir dit-il et cela passe par la
conquête affronter pour avancer
combattre réarmer un vocabulaire martial
déroulé à un rythme effrainé le Premier
ministre veut occuper l'espace ne pas le
laisser à ses adversaires politiques
malgré le Brouis un peu de silence s'il
vous plaît mes chers collègues juste un
peu de silence il a un Brouis continue
je vous remercie de bien
vouloir
merci Premier ministre je pense madame
la Présidente qu'ils ont compris que je
ne m'arrêterai pas malgré leur hurlement
et donc je peux continuer sans aucune
difficulté 1h 200 de discours au cours
duquel le Premier ministre multiplie les
annonces avec parfois un style très
direct dès le plus jeune âge il faut en
revenir à un principe clair tu casses tu
répares tu sies tu nettoies tu défies
l'autorité on t'apprend à la respecter
Gabri choisit une conclusion plus la
France ilit référ à sa situation
personnelle être français en 2024 c'est
dans un pays qu'il y a 10 ans seulement
se déchirait encore sur le mariage pour
tous pouvoir être Premier ministre en
assumant ouvertement son
homosexualité de tout cela je vois la
preuve que notre pays bouge la preuve
que les mentalités
évoluent voilà c'est d'ailleurs la seule
fois où il a parlé véritablement de lui
bonsoir Philippe machevet merci d'être
avec nous expert en communication mcbg
conseil bonsoir Mariette darégrand
plaisir de vous retrouver sémiologue et
chroniqueuse dans dans cette émission
Philippe Mor Chevrolet il a légèrement
fendu l'armure un petit peu il y avait
TR parties il y avait trois parties à
son discours il y avait une partie
service aprèsvente du président de la
République ça c'est la discipline c'est
les parti économique un peu dur et
cetera il y avait la gestion de crise
avec les agriculteurs on les a beaucoup
aidé aujourd'hui et puis la troisème
partie c'est parler de lui il a cité S
44 fois parce qu'il y a des pervers qui
ont calculé ça le mot je c'est deux ou
trois fois plus que ses prédécesseurs il
a démarré en disant je suis de la
génération de 89 donc en gros de la
chute du mur on croyait que la guerre
était finie que l'histoire s'était
arrêtée et c'est pas vrai donc il a
quand même beaucoup parlé de lui alors
c'est c'est quelque part intéressant
parce que ça ouvre une autre perspective
que la répétition du macronisme oui donc
vous vous avez vu une personnalité ou
qui n'est pas là ou qui est s'affirme
vraiment différente de celle du
président encore porte-parole il est en
train de devenir Premier ministre il
n'est pas encore Premier ministre avec
un président aussi écrasant et sans
majorité c'est de toute façon très
difficile Marielle d'gron il n'est pas
encore Premier ministre qu'est-ce que
vous retenez sur le style à tal les mots
employer ceux qui reviennent
particulièrement alors je crois qu'il y
a un vrai style déjà ce qui n'était pas
évident pour moi il y a vraiment une
rupture stylistique avec ce discours
comment vous le définiriez ce alors je
pense que c'est le mot pragmatisme qui
lui va hein on est dans une génération
née en 89 alors il a dit c'est 200 ans
après la Révolution française mais c'est
surtout en effet la chute du mur et à
partir de ce moment-là le monde devient
comme disent les Américains c'est le VI
World et là c'est instable tout est
instable c'est illisible quand on est
là-dedans et bien on le voit les
enquêtes sociologiques le montrent on
devient pragmatique on s'accroche à la
praxis on n'est pas dans la théorie on
n'est pas dans les concepts il n'y a pas
eu de mots conceptuels pas eu liberté il
n'a pas eu non il y a pas eu de mots il
y a eu espoir mais j reviendrai mais il
n a pas eu donc c'est quoi c'est la
recherche de résultat au-delà des
idéologies ou c'est la recherche de
l'action c'est le résultat de l'action
en effet c'est agir nous avons eu la
posture de
l'agissant c'est pas la posture du
guerrier pas du tout et c'est pas non
plus la la posture du disons du grand
sorcier hein si on prend la la fameuse
triade où on a le paysan le sorcier le
guerrier il est dans les agissants il il
est bien là dedans il produit des choses
il est au service d'eux et cetera donc
je crois que c'est ça qu'il faut retenir
et c'est
générationnel parce que c'est
pragmatique voilà il nous a pas entraîné
par exemple quand il a parlé du travail
il a beaucoup parlé du travail ça a été
vraiment un énorme thème le trava il y a
eu deux grands thèmes pour moi c'est la
France l'identité de la France et dire
identité française c'est rare en
politique depuis Sarkozi je crois pas
qu'on l' vraiment entendu on l'entend
quand même pas mal oui je veux dire pas
dans le clan
dans le d'extrême droite voilà de la
politique classique c'est assez rare
donc il a repris ça l'identité française
la France et le travail et le travail il
a martelé il parle au nom du travail il
travaille il agit et quand on dit qu'il
il aime le le performatif du langage ça
c'est quoi alors pour ceux qui nous
regardent on entend ça maintenant
systématiquement une action performative
un mot performatif ça veut dire quoi
alors en gros c'est lève-toi et marche
il n'y a que ça la perform mativité du
langage c'est quand le mot produit la
chose c'est c'est référé vraiment c'est
très remis en cause par les linguistes
aujourd'hui parce que il y a très très
peu de situations où le mot crée la
chose hein donc ça a été alors lui les
politiques ont le défaut de penser
qu'ils vont dire quelque chose lui je
pense que c'est pas tout à fait ça sa
performativité c'est qu'il l'incarne lui
c'est son corps on a eu un discours
corporel énergétique incarné je sais pas
si c'est bien ou mal mais c'est
différent Pascal Perino c'est vrai que
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est qu'en
général discours de politique générale
il y a des
références historiques littéraires des
mentors une généalogie politique pas du
tout là ça allait vite ça disait je
certes mais au nom du faire de l'action
voilà c'est un homme beaucoup plus
d'ailleurs du qui voudrait se présenter
comme étant un homme davantage du faire
que du dire et en tout cas le dire
référentiel qui se reporterait à des
idéologies et cetera on voit bien c'est
pas le genre de beauté de Gabriel hatal
il est dans le pragmatisme c'est un
discours en effet de pragmatisme en cela
il est très porteur très représentatif
de la culture de sa génération hein
parmi les les trentenaires certainement
beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes se sont
retrouvés dans son style un langage
simple d'autre part des phrases ah oui
sujet verbe complément ah oui des phrase
très courte très éloignée de l'aspect
par moment conceptuel extrêmement long
un peu allambiqué de son patron le
président comm vraiment pas comme
Emmanuel Macron et en cela c'est pas le
clone d'Emmanuel Mac justement on dit
souvent qu'un président et un premier
ministre doivent être complémentair ce
de la leçon ah oui c'est c'est fait pour
ça c'est fait pour être complémentaire
c'est penser comme ça le Président donne
l'impulion le cadre intellectuel et lui
vient remplir le cadre et d'ailleurs
toute la partie dure du discours c'était
vraiment le service aprèsvente du
président donc c'était la mise en re vre
de l'action pensé sout pour vous du
point de vue de la communication oui
c'est un sans fout il y a pas d'erreur
le le seul problème de Gabriel c'est pas
il va pas susciter la haine il va pas
susciter la défiance il risque de
susciter l'indifférence qui est le
contraire de l'amour voilà c'est le vrai
problème l'indifférence il y a 30 % des
Français à peu près pour qu' le
remanimement c'est intéressant mais pas
plus voilà si ils n'ont pas envie de
creuser donc ce qui risque de se passer
de pire pour lui c'est qu'il passe un
peu sous les radars il a moins de temps
que J Bardella pour installer une marque
politique il a le même problème qu'il il
a un N+ 1 assez envahissant on va dire
et
tuellaire mais il a moins de temps quoi
et puis il est moins il vient pas il a
pas le même parcours Jordan Bardella
puisque les deux vont s'opposer pour les
européennes ou tout le monde attend le
face à face oui il est là pour les
européennes c'est son test s'il perd les
européennes Gabriel natthan c'est fini
politiquement enfin pour pour un an ou
deux en tout cas pour ce quinquen mais
en tout cas c'est voilà ça va être un
match qui est intéressant aussi parce
qu'ils ont pas le même part parcours il
s'adresse aux classes moyennees ça il
l'a répété alors c'est toujours très
compliqué de savoir ce que les ce que
c'est exactement les les classes
moyennes mais en tout cas c'est la
majorité des des Français lui il il
vient pas de la classe moyenne il a à
peine 34 ans est-ce qu'il peut être
compris d'eux en tout cas il a eu alors
là pour le coup une formule une des
rares formules littéraires je ne sais
pas si on lui a soufflé si c'est une de
ses plumes je vais essayer de la
retrouver parce que c'était c'était très
intéressant il a dit c'est français de
l'Entre Deux du pays et qui en sont
pourtant le cœur battant là on est c'est
travaillé ça et j'ai trouvé que c'était
intéressant à relever parce que
justement ça faisait contraste avec son
discours très technique pragmatique et
euh alors est-ce que ça va faire de
l'effet c'est vrai que son interlocuteur
était très présent dès le début il il
s'est adressé à ses classes moyennes ça
c'est clair puisque c'est l'enjeu
vis-à-vis de du RN hein quand même c'est
maintenant tout le monde l'a vu donc
c'est intéressant là aussi je pense je
dirais pas une identification mais en
tout cas une écoute attentive de ces
classes moyennes à son égard il a fait
ce que Emmanuel Macron avait réussi en
2017 c'est-à-dire à rendre son discours
très conatif comme on dit c'est-à-dire
que le discours sencre sur
l'interlocuteur c'est pas bien bien
qu'il disent moi jeux il parle quand
même à l'autre et c'est ça c'est
fondamental quand on veut séduire il
faut partir de l'autre donc je crois que
là il a il a réussi quelque chose
il a appris ça il il l'a fait Philippe
Mor chevrelet à qui vous fait-il penser
historiquement Sarkozi je pense Nicolas
Sarkozi c'est le plus proche alors il
manque beaucoup d'éléments de Nicolas
Sarkozi il manque un côté d'abord il y a
pas le même âge il manque le côté
séducteur le côté conquérant qu'il a pas
encore parce qu' il est un peu frais
quoi Sarkozi quand il rentrait dans une
pièce Les les gens disaient qu'en fait
tous les il dominaient vraiment tous les
regards convergaient vers lui il y avait
un côté soleil est presque animal dans
la relation il a pas ça Gabriel Hatan
mais en revanche il a ce côté assertif
il a l'ambition il a le côté
aussi omni Premier ministre c'est qu'il
va être partout tout le temps il va
faire un événement par jour et puis il
déroule il a un langage effectivement
direct et simple après ce qui lui manque
pour l'instant c'est encore une fois
l'épaisseur quoi il faut remplir tout ça
il l'a pas ça c'est normal il a 34 ans
il a une voix encore un peu perchée il a
beaucoup de choses à travailler just on
va terminer là-dessus euh la patine
l'expert est-ce que un Bruno Le Maire un
Gérald Darmanin vont accepter d'être
sous ces ordres est-ce que est-ce qu'ils
vont bien le renouveau c'est plus Bruno
en tout cas vouloir se se passer du coup
de fil en direct à l'Élysée non non mais
je crois quand quand vous le regardez
fonctionner vous vous dites en tout cas
ce jeune homme ne manque pas d'autorité
et ce sont des vertus qu'on ne prête pas
spontanément à cette tranche d'âge on
dit cette tranche d'âge c'est le domaine
de l'ouverture de la permissivité et
cetera l'autorité ils en ont rien àer
pas du tout lui c'est un jeune qui
peut-être certainement permissif en
effet la fin de son discours le montre
il fait son outing enfin il ne fait pas
son outing tout le monde le savait mais
on en fait il parle à la tribune de de
son choix sexuel euh donc on on se dit
tiens c'est un un libéral culturel mais
ce libéral culturel a une autre face
c'est un homme d'autorité et en cela il
est assez révélateur de quelque chose de
très profond dans la société française
la société française elle se dit
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de liberté
privée c'est quasi inévitable c'est le
sens du changement culturel et cetera
mais en même temps cette société est de
plus en plus et on le voit tous les
jours difficile à diriger difficile à
diriger parce que les jeunes n'obéissent
plus à grand-chose parce qu'il y a les
émeutes parce qu'en classe c'est
difficile de se faire respecter et donc
il faut un peu d'ordre public alors s'il
réconcilie la liberté avec l'autorité là
Mariette pour terminer le mot de la fin
c'est gagner c'est gagné ça c'est c'est
ce serait le celui qui arrivera vraiment
dans ce pays je pense que vous avez
raison les jeunes les très jeunes ça
dépend de la tranche d'âge mais les très
très jeunes les jeunes Z qui arrivent
aiment l'autorité aime l'autorité on le
voit et ben on va on va continuer à
l'observer de près sur la forme comme
sur le fond merci beaucoup Philippe
Morau chevrelet Mariette dargand et
merci à vous Pascal Perino d'avoir été
notre grand témoin en direct ce soir
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi et bien à demain
mieux même heure très belle soirée sur
LCP bien
sûr
[Musique]